so U S income inequality is hit the highest
level in 50 years. We have just learned, and
this is measured using something called the
Guinea index. G I. N I.
Let's talk about how the metric works. This
is a measure of distribution of income or
wealth. You can have an income distribution,
a measured with Guinea or wealth distribution
and it's across income percentiles. So it
goes from zero to one. Zero would be there
is perfect equality if everyone has the same
income, the Guinea coefficient is zero. If
everyone has the same wealth, the Guinea coefficient
is zero. One would be perfect. Inequality,
meaning if it, you have a country and one
person has all the income or all the wealth,
the Guinea coefficients for income and wealth
respectively, it would be one and you can
track it over time. So in the United States
in 2017 it was 0.482 and it went up in 2018
to 0.485. It's an increase of about half a
percent. This is a very big calculation. So
it moves really, really slowly and then you
can break it down in more detail.
If you want. You could look at, let's look
at a change in the, uh, inequality, uh, by
gender or look at it by the States. People
live in blue States versus red States, or
you could look at it by race or by age or
whatever you want. Wealth inequality went
up in quite a few Heartland States, which
is interesting because Donald Trump's trade
policy, uh, is potentially to blame. They're
actually impacting inequality, uh, both income
and wealth. And some of those Heartland States,
States on the East coast and the West coast
still have higher inequality overall. And
that's really not surprising since you have
more wealthy people on the coasts and the
most equal States, interestingly enough, are
Utah, Alaska, um, and the Dakotas and maybe
Iowa as well, is on that list. And the right
loves to look at that and say, look, you've
got all these liberals who talk about equality
and they say they want equality, but it's
the red States that actually have the most
equality.
And of course this is one of those very low
energy interpretations. It's not a very, uh,
a high thinking interpretation because the
reason that a lot of red States have low inequality
is that you just have way more people that
are not doing well. And the truth is that
the degree of inequality matters. There's
lots of externalities as well, crime and others,
but the reason for inequality is also really
important. So if you want to get an understanding
of this, if you want to understand inequality,
number one, there's a lot of good books that
I could recommend that you should read, but
when you're looking at something like the
Guinea coefficient, you need to often look
qualitatively, and if I'm to pick my battles,
I have way less of a problem with an entrepreneur
who becomes wealthy by creating something
compared to someone who inherits a ton of
money and then uses the money to buy influence
and to influence legislation to allow them
to get even wealthier.
Now I want to be clear, we can argue all inequality
is a problem, whether it's inherited or whether
it's the new rich of entrepreneurship and
the tech world, but when you break it down,
there are different categories and it's important
that on the left, if we want to fight against
inequality, we should understand the sources
of it and make sure that we're dealing with
the most serious problems first. Now, that
being said, we have a system that encourages
even the entrepreneurs who become wealthy
through the business they've created to then
get into the influence pedaling and to become
one of the people that is indistinguishable
from those who have just inherited money and
use that money to peddle influence and to
change legislation for their benefit. And
then of course, you also have entrepreneurs
who are getting wealthy thanks to the tax
sheltering laws and the other stuff that the
legacy influence peddlers were able to get
past.
So it's not a clean cut the way I might be
suggesting, but the point is we should be
able to look at this issue more qualitatively
and really determine what is most important
to be addressing right away. Uh, but the reality
is that if this continues to go in the same
direction of growing inequality, it's going
to cause more social unrest. It's going to
cause more crime. It's ultimately going to
precipitate an increasingly unsustainable
system. Now the solution to the problem is
different. Depending on your political ideology.
You might have someone who is an actual socialist.
I'm not talking about someone who wants government
health care, but you might have an actual
socialist who says, the only solution is to
totally socialize the means of production,
socialized property. And that's the way that
we're going to fix this problem. Social Democrats
would have a different point of view, which
is some degree of inequality is okay, but
what we want to do is put some limits at the
top and use those to raise the floor so that
we are constricting inequality to a more narrow
band such that people aren't getting left
behind such that the riches that come to some,
the few from the system that we have are by
statute, by law being reinvested to better
circumstances for everybody.
That would be a socially democratic approach.
And that's really at the heart of a lot of
the debate that is happening within the left
right now. Uh, certainly the right has a completely
different point of view with so-called free
markets and all of the other things that they
say are really great, which have completely
failed us over the last 150 years in this
country. But the data, once again, income
inequality increasing in the United States
from 2017 to 2018